[Music]
is this thing on
so man walks into a bar he asks for ten
times more drinks than everyone else the
barman says now that is an order of
magnitude actually quite a good joke
because order of magnitude is how big a
number is a speed of light is three
times ten to the eighth meters per
second and that's the order of magnitude
it's three with eight zeros after it and
something like a kilometer is ten to the
three meters so light in one second goes
five orders of magnitude further than a
kilometer and so when he says I want ten
times as many drinks he's actually
ordering one order of magnitude more
than anyone else which is of course an
order of magnitude so an infinite number
of mathematicians walk into a bar the
first one he orders a pint the second
one half a pint then a quarter then an
eighth eventually the barman hands over
two pints and says you mathematicians
you just don't know your limits okay so
if you start with one and then you add a
half and then you add a quarter and then
you add an eighth and each time you're
getting smaller and smaller what we're
actually doing is we're summing all the
1 over 2 to the ends some end and we
start with n equals 0 and we go all the
way up to a correctly drawn infinity
sign and if you carry this on infinitely
it's limit equals 2 which is why the
barman gave them two pints and he said
you don't know your limits because
that's a limit so why is six Afraid of
seven
because seven eight nine not strictly a
math joke but okay the thing here is
that numbers appear in order they go one
two three four five six seven eight nine
why is six scared of seven when you say
seven eight nine the word eight in
English sounds a bit like the word eight
so it sounds like seven eight nine so
eight is in this case a word and seven
then eats I don't know it's I mean I
personally would say that seven
is a six offender but I'm the one doing
the jerks here am i how do you make
seven even remove the yes that was
promised number jokes but I guess
another English one is fine so the
number seven if you write it out in this
language called English which you may
have heard of you spell it seven and
then if you remove the S you're left
with the English word even no actual
maths involved two cats are standing on
a roof which one falls off first the one
with the smaller Mew
okay bear with me here I'm gonna
represent the roof like this the front
door and chimney are optional and then
I'm gonna approximate the cat as a
rectangle gravity is forcing the cat
directly down but of course it can't go
straight down because it's on a sloped
roof and so you're gonna split this into
a normal vector which comes off this way
and then the vector going down the roof
what stops it from falling off the roof
is friction and friction will be a force
coming back this way and friction is
proportional to how hard the box is
being pressed down into the roof and so
we have the coefficient of friction
which is the Greek letter mu times
whatever that normal force is and so the
bigger the coefficient of friction the
less likely it is to fall off and if
there were two boxes the one with the
smaller coefficient of friction would
fall off first and that is the Greek
letter mu which if we're talking about
cats the cats make the sound meow what
did the number zero say to the number
eight nice belt
all right okay I guess so so zero looks
a bit like this and if you imagine
putting a belt around zero and then
tightening it it would squeeze the
middle of zero in like like that and if
you tighten it enough it would pinch off
and would form an eighth and so an
eighth is a bit like a zero wearing a
belt why it is a nice belt I'm not sure
[Music]
what do you get if you cross a mosquito
with a mountain-climber
nothing you can't cross a vector and a
scalar okay there's a lot going on here
we'll start with what we mean by cross
and it's a way of saying multiply when
you multiply numbers together it's easy
there's one thing you do you multiply
one by the other when you multiply
vectors it gets a bit more complicated
so let's say I've got one vector U which
has UX component u Y component and used
edge component because it's in 3d and
then I've got another vector
I'm gonna call V so I've got V X
component V Y component the Z component
and then I want to multiply these two
vectors and there's more than one way to
do that you can dot multiply which gives
you a scalar it's just a normal number
out as an answer or you can cross
multiply using a traditional cross
multiply symbol which gives you our
another vector now cross multiplying is
a little bit complicated kay let's do
the first one so it's you y
normal multiply V Z minus u Z normal
multiply V Y then the next component you
get three new components up this way the
trouble is you can only cross multiply
vectors you can't do the same thing for
normal numbers or scalars as we call
them and someone who climbs a mountain
is scaling it so I guess you could call
him a scalar and a mosquito and we're
going right outside maths here a
mosquito can transmit diseases which in
biology you would call a vector as a way
of transmitting diseases and so you
can't do a cross multiplication between
a vector and a scalar and so that's
that's the joke did you hear the one
about the constipated mathematician
he worked it out with a pencil
ah
we're aware that there are other masked
jokes who have not covered we're also
aware that some of you have discovered
the comment section underneath YouTube
videos so if you have your own mask joke
you'd like to contribute I mean it's
like we may I'll stop you it's
definitely going to happen and we will
endeavor if we get enough interesting
ones to explain the mass behind more
mass jokes